ça c'est comets c'est avec elle que j'ai
fait tous les matins un petit promenade
ils sont belges honte à peine 60 ans et
ont décidé de tout plaquer pour venir
s'installer à feu zine un petit village
de l'indre dont elle maria et béni sont
tombés amoureux
au début des années 2000 ce que nous a
atterrés pour arriver c'est c'est ce que
vous voyez ce sont les chevaux les
terres on cherche quelque chose une
maison à la campagne et trouver ça en
flandre où sa population très dense
c'était c'était pas compliqué installer
définitivement dans la région depuis
2015 le couple se découvre une passion
pour la production d'alcool et décide
alors de transformer la vieille grange
en distillerie en manque de savoir faire
ils apprennent sur le tas ils n'hésitent
pas à demander de l'aide aux meilleurs
serviteurs en belgique fait des cours
pour le distillateur venus ici pour une
semaine fait un travail artisanal avec
une volonté de redonner vie aux recettes
du berry entre news et billy ratafia à
marjah est bénie produisent 4000
bouteilles par an uniquement à base de
matières premières locales
à l'époque les gens il se faisait ça où
se fait un peu plaisir
il n'avait pas de magasins et se
trouvaient tout ça au delà de la fermer
nous avons juste continuer de le faire
de la même façon passons méthodes
traditionnelles
le grand prix final exceptionnel vendu
au domaine entre 17 et 30 euros
les bouteilles de nos berrichon
d'adoption se retrouve aujourd'hui à la
carte d'une vingtaine de restaurants
gastronomiques à consommer toutefois
avec modération